let's talk about one of the most
secretive countries in the world and
what happens when covet hits
north korea says it's kept the virus out
for the last two years but not anymore
north korea has acknowledged its very
first cases of covert 19. supreme leader
kim jong-un said the country faced great
turmoil and ordered a lockdown of all
cities
no one's vaccinated testing capacity is
seriously limited and the health care
system is weak wha is deeply concerned
at the risk of further spread of covet
19 in the country it's already a
economically impoverished country so
it's just going to make matters worse so
what do we know about what's happening
and did north korea really keep cobit
out all this time
here's a throwback it's january 20th
2020. a new coronavirus has been
identified in china spreading from the
city of wuhan there have been
282 confirmed cases across four
countries and the world is only just
starting to make sense of it all but
north korea takes action even before the
chinese authorities lock down the
province which
is in the north koreans stopped all
travel and sealed their borders
so this is not something new they've
done the same thing for sars mers and
ebola and north korea basically kept
this up until january this year and says
there were zero cases in all that time
but the thing about north korea is that
it's almost impossible to get accurate
information
and there have been various reports of
coveted cases there over the last two
years there were a lot of reports about
fever outbreaks or people getting sick
in a certain city and the residents
didn't really know if it was covered but
they suspected it was coveted what we do
know is that on may 12th the government
admitted it had a problem it announced
it had detected the omicron variant and
it was spreading fast and some north
korea watchers reckon that two big
public celebrations back in april could
have been super spreader events
since the big announcement state media
has been reporting daily figures for
what they're calling a fever by may 18th
they'd hit the 2 million mark and
confirmed 63 deaths but the number of
new cases appeared to have peaked a
couple days later keep in mind though
these figures come with a couple of
caveats so there's a little asterisk
every time we talk about new cases in
north korea right because what they're
reporting are the number of cases with
fever and it speaks directly to the fact
that they completely lack capacity to
monitor and run tests on these cases to
confirm as with anything that's dealing
with north korea and the internal
situation we're basically going by what
the north korean government is is
publicizing to its internal and also
its external audiences now remember
omicron is less deadly than earlier
covert 19 variants but it's super
infectious and north korea is
particularly vulnerable no one has been
vaccinated so it's going to rip through
the population the leadership has
repeatedly refused offers of vaccines
including from kovacs the global vaccine
program their refusal to vaccinate their
population was really based on that
the belief that the prevention would
work and could stay on until the
pandemic is over i don't know if it's as
much of a concern about
their reputation abroad or the
you know being beholden to a foreign
party because of receiving vaccines it
might just be because they don't want to
risk personnel and foreigners coming
into the country going around the
country typical concerns about seeing
the real state of things and then there
are other problems with north korea's
health care system now by some measures
it's not too bad for a low-income
country for example they have plenty of
trained doctors nurses and technicians
but they're dealing with serious
shortages including of basic drugs like
paracetamol
the other thing is the lack of resources
in terms of medical equipment
being able to exchange
information with outside world that's
also severely limited and then on top of
that you have the international
sanctions which also shackles north
korea's
ability to get parts
for some of the equipment i've seen a
lot of photos of the of clinics in rural
parts of the country and they look
extremely dire no stockpile of equipment
really poor
equipment and supplies
very dirty not sanitary that could be
common in in some certain rural areas in
bigger cities
there are of course hospitals but
i just don't think that they're up to
international standards another thing to
remember is that this virus is sweeping
through a population where millions of
people are malnourished 42 according to
the u.n north korea has always struggled
to feed its people and over the last two
years there have been extra problems
north korea depends on imports from
china for many staple foods but when
they shut the border to keep out kovid
it also meant a lot of that food wasn't
coming in
a drought in 2020 and floods the
following year hurt farming and hit
production and when you've got a
population that's not well fed they're
going to be more vulnerable to disease
we know for instance in case of the
tuberculosis uh
disease
that north korea is one of the countries
with the highest burdens of that and
that speaks to the
sort of overall weak immune system of
the north korean population so how is
north korea tackling its covet outbreak
well the government launched what it's
calling a maximum emergency epidemic
prevention system it includes a national
lockdown with shops restaurants markets
and schools reportedly closed
but as always it's hard to know exactly
what the picture is and the differences
between the cities and the countryside i
haven't seen any evidence that police
are setting up walls or um boarding up
doors of buildings like we've seen in
in shanghai recently for example but
we've seen
blocked off streets a lot of shots of
empty streets it's really unclear at
this point but
um it seems to be that there's
hmi lockdown
regional lockdown but then potentially
exceptions state media has released
video of a factory that's still running
and grocery stores and pharmacies that
are open the army has been drafted in to
deliver medical supplies there's also a
public information campaign on things
like social distancing and washing hands
and recommending gargling with salt
water
[Music]
foreign
now when it comes to outside help there
have been plenty of offers including
from south korea the us and the who
but none have been accepted we've
offered vaccines we've got no response
we have offered support
in the form of technical assistance in
the form of medical supplies
tests vaccines
and we are
ready to deploy those the problem is
less about the
world's openness and
you know the readiness to help the north
korean population it has more to do with
the regimes
just being completely closed
to any form of outside help that is
going to
one expose the the vulnerabilities of
the country
and also too
it's also going to reflect poorly upon
kim's own competence as a leader but
north korea may have already turned to
its closest friend china for support
it looks like three cargo planes from
the state airline recently made a trip
to china they're thought to be the
airline's first flights out of the
country in the last two years
reports from south korean media suggest
they could have been picking up medical
supplies
ten days after north korea announced its
first coveted cases state media reported
that they're successfully overcoming the
crisis that the government's response
was working the official tally showed
the number of new cases coming down and
a total of just 66 deaths
but again this is north korea we're
talking about and its track record
suggests we need to be extremely
cautious about trusting the leadership
to be transparent when dealing with a
crisis
in case you missed it take a look at our
last episode on the tragic killing of al
jazeera's journalist shadeen abu akkle
[Music]